so for somebody who's maybe grappling
with their own discontentment
what is the recommendation or the advice
that you could give to that person to
help them kind of reckon with it figure
out what you love doing go back to when
you were three we'll figure out what you
think you like doing or better to love
doing it and then um figure out how to
make that your life what the goal okay I
love doing this how do I make that a
career and then you make the road map
you make the blueprint and you follow it
and you'll be doing it and as I said
don't stay rigidly attached if it morphs
to another Direction go check that out
um if if you achieve it and you're
really here and you're like oh this
isn't what I thought it was going to be
then go at it again I always visualize a
positive outcome and always work on
being positive and seeing success